the mandalorian wrapped up its sophomore
season on disney plus and within its
roughly 45-minute run time it packed
plenty of action surprises and huge
moments
spoilers for chapter 16 in the
mandalorian the rescue ahead
the episode picks up as mando and his
intrepid gang of pals embark on a risky
mission to invade an imperial ship
rescue grogu and defeat empire higher up
mop gideon
in the process that caused a whole lot
of havoc including smashing through the
ship's front door with a stolen imperial
shuttle and dispatching several platoons
of stormtroopers
separated from the group mando stalks
through the imperial ship to find in
free grogu
and finds moff gideon already waiting
there for him the two end up dueling in
hand-to-hand combat
after a pretty spectacular fight scene
mando best moff gideon once and for all
bringing him to bogatan who wanted to
defeat the villain herself as a prize
however in defeating moff gideon mando
has created an interesting new problem
as the imperial boss explains according
to mandalorian custom the darksaber
belongs only to whomever wins it in
battle
and that determines who can sit on the
throne of mandalore mando offers her the
darksaber several times but she doesn't
take it
and the crew is attacked by dark
troopers before we find out how this
conflict is resolved
mando seemingly already agreed to help
poketan take back the planet of
mandalore back when he and boba fett
approached her for help at the beginning
of the episode
but their new conflict certainly throws
a monkey wrench into the works
clearly these two allies will be at odds
now that mando has become the apparent
chosen one
sadly it seems as if the cutest cast
member of the mandalorian may appear on
the show a little less frequently going
forward
if he shows up again at all at the end
of the episode when all hope seems lost
the jedi ends up answering grosgu's call
that he clearly sent out from the jedi
temple in the tragedy
in an exciting twist it's none other
than luke skywalker himself
thanks to some clever de-aging
technology used on original star wars
actor mark hamill rogue is drawn to luke
who's joined by beloved droid r2d2
but he's still hesitant to leave his
surrogate father after mando grants
permission and is assured that luke will
protect the tiny creature with his life
he says a heartbreaking goodbye to grogu
in the episode's sweetest moment mando
even removes his helmet letting grosgu
see his real face
grogu is destined to train with luke all
along and what will become of the
adorable creature under the master
jedi's tutelage and how much he'll
appear on the mandalorian going forward
remains to be seen
hopefully we'll find out if he avoided
the fate suffered by some of luke's
other students at the hands of kylo ren
and his followers additionally mando
removing his helmet also spells big
changes for our hero going forward
this is now the second time in his many
episodes that he's chosen to break his
oath to follow the way
and show his face to other living beings
the first time he did it and the
believer he did it to accomplish his
goal of finding grogu's location
this time however he did it so he could
better connect with his surrogate son
just like when luke helped remove the
darth vader helmet from his father's
head at the end of return of the jedi
while mando's future seems inextricably
linked with the retaking of mandalore
his commitment to the mandalorian ideals
he was raised with seems weaker than
ever
how will that impact his alliance with
boca tan
seeing a young luke skywalker who
judging by his incredible decimation of
every single dark trooper is in its
prime was a pretty big surprise but in
the aftermath of a spectacular second
season fans are left wondering who else
might end up returning to the
mandalorian as the series moves forward
beyond original trilogy favorites like
luke and bob characters like bokutan and
ahsoka tano have shown up in live action
appearances after winning over audiences
in the clone wars the beloved animated
star wars series
since then fans have been hoping to see
other animated star wars characters like
star wars rebels ezra bridger or grand
admiral thrawn
obviously that didn't happen in season 2
but in the mandalorian's third season
there's a whole galaxy of possibilities
ahead
and as for ahsoka you'll be able to
catch her in her own standalone series
soon which will more than likely be
where bridger and thrawn come back into
play
meanwhile we never explicitly find out
just what moff gideon wanted grogu's
blood for but we know that dr pershing
is an imperial cloning engineer
and we also saw very snokelike shapes
floating in tanks in the imperial
base at mando kara dune and grief karga
infiltrated back in chapter 12 the siege
it's never explicitly stated but it
seems like a good bet that grogoo's
force-powered blood is what helped
create supreme leader snoke and
resurrect emperor palpatine for episode
9 the rise of skywalker
but will we ever find out if this is the
case for sure or is there another evil
purpose grogu's blood serves for the
empire
after saying goodbye to the main cast
the post-credits scene showed bib
fortuna job of the hutt's right-hand man
last seen in return of the jedi
lounging on his boss's old throne boba
fett's partner fenik shan easily
dispatches bib fortuna's henchman
and then boba proceeds to kill biportuna
himself if you're wondering how bib
fortuna actually survived the events of
return of the jedi to only be killed in
this episode of the mandalorian
you're not alone bib fortuna's last
on-screen appearance was on jabba's
barge which was thoroughly exploded by
luke skywalker han solo princess leia
and the rest of the gang
but while we never saw bib fortuna make
his escape into the tatooine desert
we'll just have to assume he jumped
ship at the first sign of trouble after
all if boba fett can survive being
literally swallowed by a horrific sand
monster
bib fortuna could probably hitch a ride
back to the palace
anyway after big fortuna's unceremonious
execution fennick perches next to
jabba's throne while boba takes the seat
as his own
immediately after the scene ends the
official announcement arrives
a new series the book of boba fett will
arrive on the service in december of
2021
potentially along with the next season
of the mandalorian as if it wasn't
exciting enough to see boba in action
this season in the mandalorian news that
tamura morrison will be starring in an
entire series focused on the character
is the star wars bombshell
more details about the book of boba fett
will undoubtedly emerge soon but for now
it's thrilling enough to know that we'll
get an entire series devoted to bobop
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you